muito senti muito bem o pessoal de quem
fala sou eu levo daqui dos treinos e os
estragos e que slater ponto e não
pessoal hoje o conflito continua vai ser
diferente não é só jogar não é só o
plenário lhe matar cobras não né
hoje vai ser um desafio no twitter ponte
o desafio é o seguinte sempre que uma
cobra me apanhar o texto como uma destas
lagartas da selva indígenas da amazônia
filos paulo é chamam-se dois planos por
espíritos principais flickr
as formas são larvas disseram é ó isto
que eu comer grilos como sempre o que
não se diz que é bom eo que está também
é mais caro atenção preste um desafio à
corre a coca
eu não vou comer tem como que deseja ou
seja sempre que uma escrita me apanhar
eu vou fazer a contagem e no final do
vídeo eu vou comer o equivalente às
minhocas me apanhar ou seja se um
recinto vezes durante o vídeo eu vou ter
que comer cinco funk minhocas de célula
é vamos começar então embora continuasse
um estilo minhoca
vejam só acho que o planeta 2.500 doida
agora eu sei que não posso perder sabem
porque para poder comer o melhor já não
lembro como é que se joga agora vamos
tentar apanhar alguém não já que
arriscar depois virão e pitéu pois o v
[Música]
o tupi também é bem amiga
calma calma calma temos que ir com calma
mandar que ainda agora consegui jantou
em mim para assim vai vai começa a olhar
e envolveu um surra descobrir por sylvio
cesco riso não vai ganhar é o jato muito
grande para nossa saúde está em risco
vocês são tudo por tudo né pois tenho o
meu filho e cobra bebê então um filho
fosse contra o pai então tentar apanhar
esta campanha a meu ver um pouco maior
mas não vou comer
tudo bem já vou tirar um ok aqui ó
o cheiro até o vôo em um pacote o canadá
deu se uma hutu viva esta vai ser a
minha atenção
eu acredito que minha mãe filho que é um
site do joelho como minhoca como um
alcance o mestre do samba zone uma
minhoca já está agora já repararam que
eu tenho o julinho mesmo quando juninho
eo pec é impossível este lugar sempre
alguém melhor que você assim com algumas
de arte chinês que eu também tenho
límbico mas pronto nunca ganhar o tato
chiclete atualizem os servidores letras
ponto o choque pessoal encontrar de
nossa primeira empresa está a afundar
fugir e fugir como se fosse uma vez ela
fugir num nível mas não tinha essa
vantagem o time vai tentar pegar o
desvio vai mas é uma pena uma galinha é
do piolho que meu vasco nesta linha
studio minha pensa que é mais perto do
que ela mas não vai conseguir pagar o
carioca está tudo mais calmo agora nós
precisamos preparar recuado para voltar
a crescer agora temos que escolher uma
nova empresa
filha da mãe quis me comer mas não
deixei uma calma boi boi boi vai meu gol
só os corpos ainda vêm ok vamos tentar
uma empresa mais pequena não é enviado
nem é uma vez ela eu sou muito ruim o
outro hospital que não quis falar que
estou aqui já será inscrito o segredo é
por serem fãs estão mitchell frango e
ferro e puxamos viram as costas a pensar
que vocês são amigos e de repente
aparece uma cobra muito maior vamos
tentar apanhar esta é sempre gostoso
olho por isso a ela estava fechada que
então não não não não isso é injusto eu
não chamo muito injusto ela vai obrigar
a um número maior flamengo não pode né
olha eu morri mais de uma hora vinha bem
gostosa olha aqui já segundo a lei duas
larvas no olímpico eu adoro adoro pitéu
fripp deu de graça e sempre bons
conselhos graça pp optou de prova em do
filho eis mais uma larva 30 larva não
vai mexer uma doença no estômago é muito
pitéus a rota ainda agora como seja
[ __ ] não pode ser meu tenho a mais
pequena do mec o nome aqui olha outro
ponto entrei agora já nem
no andar melhor e nunca deu um olhar de
deus meu deus olha outra 2000 e julgada
épica mas pronto vamos fazer o que é
justo que é comer no olha o tamanho
dessa larva é uma larga astronauta
nicole na compreensão esta parece que
saiu dentro desta lei muito grande
quatro árvores não gostou
vamos tentar fazer mais umas nada destas
ou pelo menos sobreviver o hospital ele
já comeu tudo meu deus uma pessoa que
passar fome e eu sou o primeiro em tudo
e ruins teste foi na quarta-feira à
angop tem um pitéu pi tem que ter muito
bem a lei mas não largo agora cinco
nunca possuiu que são essas bolinhas de
arquivar 11 isto o tubo gol só queria
comer uma bolinha voador é mas ele nunca
deu foi morto a mas eu agora duvido que
nesta tentativa deles comem duas novas
progresso visível perderam 3 com duas ea
como duas formas por aí
se eu perder outra vez com mais duas mas
se eu entrar pelo menos no top 10 o pds
quando surge isto cnet juntos o filme
aceito mesmo à espera mas faltam tenho
uma aqui perto tem seis para comer se eu
perder eu vou comer 18 tinham poder não
vai comer isso tudo a atenção no nome f
eo e melhor armado ele só que mais lhe
que você usa não come não posso perder
agora não posso não posso mil oito
larvas vai contudo como tudo muito
relaxado isso agora fosse novo faz logo
da pt deu há muita cobra grande ícone
aquela cósmico uuuuuuhhhhh olha vou te
matar muita cobra mulheres picchu
meu deus não tá muito difícil está muito
difícil não sentir pontos era só 900
pontos
eu não vinha a subir ao pódio mais uma
vez na pessoa do abortivo só mais uma
vez a questão é com a estratégia que tem
mais volta de 3 faz supor desde quinta e
treine no rat eu vou eu vou eu vou agora
para fazer macumba e traz quase irmã
cuba depois de uma cobrança aqui uma
cobra uma boa pequena são aquelas que um
simples até que querem avançar quando se
esperam apoio estima ter uma cobra das
leis aqui esta pequena ela tem de
controlar a alta foi muito bem jogado à
escola esta espécie e cobra a velha ea
nova espécie e cobra a equipe teu pai
aqui jaz a prole nana já não vou à lei
ainda bem que não fui eu toco 1000
pontos estão 10 mil e as 9 mil l índice
no americano de campos somente torna o
sorridente olha no que deu no que deu no
que deu
lixo falei alguma dessas vão querer eu
vou aproveitar aqui eu vou na equipe era
o quadro 28 briga foi pequena tentar por
gabi como assim toda sempre ao meu lado
olha aí nova espécie a cobra velha
voltou uma cobra foi comida ali o outro
aqui vai vai com tudo como tudo
controlar e do vice campeões
gostoso um outro com quatro mil pontos
ou alta 6 mil para cobrar vale atentar
na campanha ela é perigosa ela tem razão
em ruas daqui pra frente em ruanda fugir
olha no que deu
leisler kiep não estou porque não muito
muito mesmo ok
o objetivo é um aperitivo o jato 15 mil
eu vou vomitar falta lutado não pode ter
sucumbido aqui e esta nova técnica e do
caracol e sem peso tipo subir porque em
carro que parou aí o caminho o tempo
informou
foi aí que o piloto foi quase ficou
amigo para uma cuba livre no campeonato
carioca muito louca eu tenho que me fará
mais três mais três uma e terminar duas
três fatah não tá muito muito minhoca
que eu vou comigo olha o cão eu quebrei
busca provar uma década passada manhã em
salvador embora calma sua provável saiba
qualquer coisa sica bora bora bora bora
entre as duas um gol do bota
[Música]
ai eu não sou o senhor não investiga
tudo aquilo a que não não olha olha aí o
sangue delas se o puxa estava fácil não
fosse o mínimo problema nos complicou
nunca como minhoca em casa sabe até de
campo diego pessoal para que vocês
tenham gostado tanto quanto você acha
que favorito já sabem nunca como um lava
em casa não se armem em deus porque
vocês não são roque o ex-tenista mostra
foi geisy mundo como funk favorito fique
bem e me aproximei e disse que o irmão
dele que o mangá histórias horizonte
tudo isto em um copo